today we have with us as well kaylee
mcinnani
kaylee is our co-host of outnumbered and
she's the former white house press
secretary kaley it's so great to have
you on the show today
you saw griff's report um we know that
kamala harris hasn't come to the
come to the border we know it's a
disaster down there
do you think they know that it's a
disaster and that they just don't care
this is exactly what they want to have
happen
i think that's exactly right but first
i'd be remiss if i didn't congratulate
you on your first day rachel
i loved watching those beautiful images
of your family and i'm just i'm so happy
for you and all of your fox colleagues
me included are cheering you on but to
the serious matter that we're discussing
there's no doubt about
it kamala harris joe biden jen sake are
all directly responsible for this the
children those young girls you saw
thrown over the wall that heartbreaking
video of the boy saying
they left me they left me the fact that
we've seen a
triple threefold increase of people
dying crossing our border
it sounds harsh but it is true they are
responsible when you say there is free
health care in this country if you come
across the border when you say we will
welcome children with open arms
you send children into the hands of the
coyotes do not take it from me
take it from the guatemalan president
who said that very thing the same
president that kamala harris just sat
across from
i want to switch topics for you really
quick and we do we don't have a lot of
time left
but i do want to get your thoughts on
putin you know he spoke out ahead of the
meeting
that he's going to have with joe biden
he praised your former boss president
trump
he called biden a career man what do you
think what's he up to
oh well what he's up to is doing what
he's always done which is
mislead the media they buy it hook line
and sinker
he convinced this country that president
trump was an agent of russia he did that
through the russian dossier
the media the best propagandist for
russia they could possibly have the
american media
carried his water and that's what he's
doing again he fears president trump who
put sanctions on him
who wouldn't allow nordstrom 2 to happen
a big geopolitical win that joe biden
reversed and
basically greenlighted uh and it leads
me to ask as david harassani said at the
new york post
what does vladimir putin have on joe
biden because joe biden is carrying his
water
and so too is the american media great
point the chinese and the russians
probably have a lot on him
thanks a lot kaylee really appreciate it
thanks rachel congratulations again
thanks